the 2023 cost of a data breach report
including key findings and important
recommendations all on this episode of
IBM Tech now what's up y'all my name is
Ian and I am back to bring you the
latest and greatest news and
announcements about IBM technology
IBM Securities cost of a data breach
report quips I.T risk management and
Security leaders with quantifiable
evidence to help them better manage
their security Investments risk profile
and strategic decision-making processes
this year's research studied 553
organizations impacted by data breaches
that occurred between March 2022 and
March 2023.
the breaches took place across 16
countries and regions and in 17
different Industries
the report examines the root causes in
both the short-term and long-term
consequences of data breaches it also
explores the factors and technologies
that enable companies to limit losses or
in some cases increase their costs
we're going to cover some of the key
findings and recommendations in this
episode but to read the full report
click the link in the description of
this video
first and foremost among the key
findings of the 2023 cost of a data
breach report was that the average cost
of a data breach reached an all-time
high in 2023 of 4.45 million US dollars
this represents a 2.3 percent increase
over 2022 and an astounding 15.3 percent
increase over 2020.
security Ai and automation were shown to
be important Investments for reducing
costs and minimizing time to identify
and contain breaches
organizations that extensively use these
capabilities experienced on average a
108 day shorter time to identify and
contain the breach
they also reported lower data breach
costs to the tune of 1.76 million
this year's report also shows that
excluding law enforcement from
ransomware incidents led to higher costs
while 63 percent of respondents said
that they involved law enforcement the
37 percent that didn't paid almost 10
percent more and experienced a 33-day
longer breach life cycle
and finally only one-third of companies
discovered the data breach through their
own security teams highlighting a need
for better threat detection
67 percent of breaches were reported by
a benign third party or by the attackers
themselves
when attackers disclosed a breach it
cost organizations nearly 1 million more
compared to internal detection
the 2023 cost of a data breach report
outlines four main steps you can take to
help reduce the financial and
reputational impacts of a data breach
first build security into every stage of
software development and deployment and
test regularly
second modernize data protection across
hybrid cloud
third use security Ai and automation to
increase the speed and accuracy of
identifying and containing a breach
and fourth strengthen resiliency by
knowing your attack surface and
practicing incident response
for a more in-depth look at each of
these recommendations hit the link below
to read the full report
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of IBM Tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics I've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in Tech now
this